music
Good evening. Welcome to the table.
My name is James. Pronouns are he and him.
We got a few announcements to start off.
First announcement, we have
Not Your Mama Sunday School class
beginning one week from today on Sunday
April 21st at 3pm.
We're launching our first
sprint style meet up called Not Your Mama
Sunday School class. A sprint meet up
is one that only starts for a short amount of time.
In this case, the class will meet for five
Sundays only from 3 to 4
30pm right here at
Saxy First. It's a class for anyone
who wants to read and discuss the Bible
in a way that considers scholarship
and welcomes diversity of thought.
You don't need to sign up. Simply show up here
at 3pm next week with your Bible
in an open heart and mind.
Then we have the Welcome to the Table
class two weeks from today on Sunday
April 28th from 3 to
4.30pm right here at Saxy First again.
We're offering a class to facilitate
by Pastor Brett designed both for
those wanting more information about the table
as well as those wanting to make this community
their official church home. If that sounds like you
then scan the QR code to sign up.
Now,
let me give you a minute to settle
to finish filling out a form, put away your
cell phone.
Allow the cares of the world to fall away.
Now we enter a sacred space.
A space for prayer,
worship, and adoration.
A space where we center on Christ.
The one who made us, who sees us,
and who loves us.
So don't feel like you have to figure
everything out.
Don't feel like you have to force a change.
Simply open yourself
to whatever God has for you.
Simply open yourself to what
God has for you. We have come
to worship.
So let's worship well.
Thank you so much.
Would you guys stand with us?
We're going to get started with brighter days and I know
I know enough of you to know that our days are not always bright.
There have been mixes of storms
and clouds and rain and chaos
for so many of us and I hope that as we start this
service together that we can hold on to a little bit of hope.
That those days do come to an end.
And sometimes even in the midst of the storm, we find
that center of peace, that center of God's love
and calm and let's hold on to that together.
Alright?
Brighter days
Oh, ashes
fall like
mirroring dreams
Oh, never live through
times like these
Oh, if you're trying
hard to breathe
in the dark
again
I know there's gonna be
some brighter days
I swear the love will
find you in your pain
I feel it in me
like the beating of life
in my veins
I know there's gonna be
some brighter days
Oh, if your screams
make a sound
Oh, if your walls
are crashing down
Oh, if your heart just
cries too loud
all the time
Oh
I know there's gonna
be some brighter days
I swear the love will
find you in your pain
I feel it in me
like the beating of life
in my veins
I know there's gonna be
some brighter days
Oh, oh, oh, oh
Brighter days
I know there's gonna
be some brighter days
I swear the love will
find you in your pain
I feel it in me
like the beating of life
in my veins
I know there's gonna
be some brighter days
I swear the love will
find you in your pain
I feel it in me
like the beating of life
in my veins
I know there's gonna
be some brighter days
All right kiddos. Thank you
for clapping along and
leaving us there. You guys
are dismissed to go to your
classes and your teachers are
going to be over at the doors
waiting for you so please
follow them. And can
we just give a quick hand
to our kids' ministry team
who is serving them.
A big thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Y'all are the best
As they transition
over to their class we are going to transition
into the prayers of the people.
For some of you I know it's your first
time so this is just a portion
of our service that is
kind of a tradition back in church
history where we're going to read
through a prayer liturgy together
and then we'll leave
some room and space for you
to say out loud
a person or a situation
that you're carrying on your heart tonight
and we'll just lift those up together
as a community before God
and then we will read the rest of the prayer
and close that out.
Would you guys read along
with me please?
Jesus, for this city
of Saxe, Texas and
for every city and community
and all who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth you have given us
and the wisdom and the
will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick
for the widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the
oppressed, the unemployed
and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
for the vulnerable, the marginalized
and those unjustly
targeted for their gender, sexuality
race or other
perceived difference
we pray to you
for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection
and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health
we pray to you
Lord, we know that you love
us and that you hear us
so we lift these
and situations up
to you
We pray to you
for the good earth you
have given us
and the wisdom and
the will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old
and the sick
for the poor
and the injustly
targeted for their gender, sexuality
race or other
perceived difference
we pray to you
amen
for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud
and for those that we have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they
may have life and light
healing
and hope, peace
and a deep sense of your
presence, amen
music
Christ is my firm
foundation
the rock
on which I stand
when everything
around me is shaking
but I've
never been
more glad
that I put my faith
in Jesus
cause
he's never
let me down
he's faithful through
generations
so
why would
he fail now
he won't
no he won't
and
I've still got joy
in my eyes
I've
got peace that
makes no sense
so I won't be
going under
I'm
not held by my
own strength
cause I've built my life
on Jesus
he's never
let me
down
he's faithful in every
season
so why
would he fail now
he won't
he won't fail
the life on which I stand
and everything around me shaking
I've never been more glad
that I put my faith in Jesus
he's never let me down
he's faithful through generations
so why would he fail now
he won't
he won't fail
He won't
fail
sing this together
the rain came
the winds blew
but my house was built on you
and I'm safe
with you
I'm gonna make it
through
the rain came
the winds blew
but my house was built
on you
I'm safe
with you
I'm gonna make
it through
the rain came
the winds blew
but my house was built
on you
and I'm safe
with you
and I'm gonna make
it through
the rain came
the winds blew
but my house was built
on you
and I'm safe
with you
and I'm gonna make
it through
I'm gonna make
cause I'm standing
strong on you
I'm gonna make
it through
cause my house was built
on you
I'm gonna make
it through
cause I'm standing
strong on you
and I'm gonna make
it through
cause my house was built
on you
guitar solo
Christ is my firm foundation
the rock on which I stand
when everything around me is shaking
I've never been more glad
that I put my faith in Jesus
cause He's never
let me down
He's faithful
through generations
so why would He fail now
cause I'm standing
strong on you
and I'm gonna make
it through
the rain came
the winds blew
but my house was built
on you
and I'm gonna make
it through
cause my house was built
on you
and I'm gonna make
it through
a God full of compassion
He protects the simple hearted
when I was in great need
He saved me
be at rest once more
oh my soul
for the Lord has been
good to you
for you, oh Lord
have delivered my soul from death
my eyes from tears
my feet from stumbling
that I may walk before the Lord
in the land of the living
all my words fall short
I've got nothing new
how could I express
all my gratitude
that I could sing these songs
as I often do
but every song must end
and you never do
so I throw up my hands
praise you again and again
cause all that I have
is a hallelujah
hallelujah
and I know it's not much
but I've nothing else
fit for a king
except for a heart singing
hallelujah
I've got one response
I've got just one move
with my arms stretched wide
and I will worship you
so I throw up my hands
praise you again and again
cause all that I have
is a hallelujah
hallelujah
and I know it's not much
but I've nothing else
fit for a king
except for a heart singing
hallelujah
guitar solo
oh come on my soul
don't you get shy on me
lift up your song
cause you've got a lion
inside of those lungs
get up and praise the lord
oh come on my soul
don't you get shy on me
lift up your song
cause you've got a lion
inside of those lungs
get up and praise the lord
oh come on my soul
don't you get shy on me
lift up your song
cause you've got a lion
inside of those lungs
get up and praise the lord
oh come on my soul
don't you get shy on me
lift up your song
cause you've got a lion
inside of those lungs
get up and praise the lord
oh come on my soul
don't you get shy on me
lift up your song
cause you've got a lion
inside of those lungs
get up and praise the lord
yeah
so i throw up my hands
and praise you again
cause all that i have
is hallelujah
hallelujah
and i know it's not much
nothing else can fill it
all that i have
is hallelujah
hallelujah
yes god whatever we have
we want to spend it on you
god we want to hang on
to whatever hope you've given us
whatever forgiveness you have shown us
through our life god
whatever grace you have paved
over our broken pavement
god whatever light has broken through
would we hang on to those tonight
would we hang on to those this week
would we remember that you are a good god
that you never leave
you never forsake
you never give up
but you are with us
emmanuel
a god who is here
with every breath that we breathe
with every pump of our heart
god your grace
your love
your goodness
would it carry us forward
would it carry us to our very best selves
would it carry us into a broken world
where we can be healers
where we can be lovers
where there have been haters god
where we could be light in dark places
god we hang on to you
our rock
our redeemer
our anchor
and we love you
and that's a good god
thank you for this time together
thank you for a community
who wants to see each other
who wants to change the world
for the better
god keep doing your work in us
in your name i pray, amen
guys thank you so much for worshipping together with us
would y'all turn to the people around you
just say hello and then
Brett will get us started on our message
thanks
well grace and peace
it is so good to be with you
so so good
I'm grateful to be with you in this space
and to welcome all of you
and as always that includes of course everyone
but including those joining us online
and especially anyone tonight who is new
in this space
I know it can be a lot
walking through those double doors
and you know
especially depending on church backgrounds
and how awesome or poorly
your last experience in a church was
you know it can be a lot
so I'll just say thank you
for having the courage to push through
and we just want you to know that you are
wanted and welcome in this space
so we are in a season
of the church calendar
known as Easter Tide
and I don't know about you
but I came from a tradition
that only did like a day of Easter
and so I was kind of delighted
when I found out like most
not all but most of the broader church
actually celebrates 40 days of Easter
kind of in the same way
you have the season of Lent
which like leads up to
you know Good Friday the Day of the Cross
and it makes sense
on the back side you would have
you know 40 days of Easter
and resurrection life
and so with that in mind
we're doing a series right now
titled Practicing Resurrection
where I mean it's one thing
to sort of you know believe
or whatever in the resurrection of Christ
but it's like yeah
but what does that mean exactly
like how do we live into that
express that truth
in helpful life-giving
beautiful ways in the world
so because that we're following
what's known as the church lectionary
kind of the prescribed scriptural readings
and so there's always one
from the Book of Acts
at least in this kind of year
of the calendar
and so that's kind of
what we're following along
is how the early church
kind of lived into
this resurrection life
and what we can learn from it
so with that in mind
the title of my message
is What They Need
What They Need
and the lectionary
actually this week
we're deviating a little bit
because it would be
Acts 3 12 through 19
is like the kind of scheduled reading
I want to do the broader story though
so verses 1 through 10
to kind of lay some of the background
and it's such a
it's just a beautiful
remarkable story
so Acts 3 1 through 10
One day Peter and John
were going up to the temple
at the time of prayer
at three in the afternoon
Now a man who was lame from birth
was being carried to the temple gate
called Beautiful
where he was put every day
to beg from those
going into the temple courts
When he saw Peter and John
about to enter
he asked them for money
Peter looked straight at him
as did John
Then Peter said
Look at us
So the man gave them his attention
expecting to get something from them
Then Peter said
Silver or gold
I do not have
But what I do have
I give to you
In the name of Jesus Christ of Nazareth
Walk
Taking him by the right hand
he helped him up
And instantly the man's feet
and ankles became strong
He jumped to his feet
and began to walk
Then he went with them
into the temple courts
walking and jumping
and praising God
When all the people saw him
walking and praising God
they recognized him
as the same man
who used to sit begging
at the temple gate
called Beautiful
And they were filled with wonder
and amazement
at what had happened to him
It's a beautiful story, isn't it?
So I want to unpack this a little bit
by actually beginning with
what I think is maybe
a little bit of a misreading
because on the one hand
this is like an incredible story
but it might feel a little bit
I don't know, removed
So I'm going to talk a little bit
in the first part about how
I don't think it's
this is an instance where
Peter and John are being stingy
with their money
I don't think that's a good reading
of the story
And I also want to talk a little bit
about the whole kind of signs and wonders
aspect of this
Some of you know I have like a
kind of Pentecostal charismatic
like background I guess
Not Pentecostal actually
but charismatic kind of background
Though I've sort of journeyed
through that movement
and out the other side
And so although there's much beauty there
I want us to kind of think about
well, what might this mean
kind of in light of that
without maybe slipping into
some of the shadow
kind of unhelpful sides of that
So that's kind of where we're going
So let's unpack this
a little bit of the
misreading of this being like
a story of stinginess
The whole silver and gold
I do not have
while they're like money bags
jingle or something
I don't think that's what's happening
So I mean I can imagine
like a Christian
There's like this thing
where Christians go to lunch
after like Sunday morning service
And they're known
I mean sadly in like
the restaurant industry
It's known as like
just the cheapest
It's like one of the
most worst tips ever
And I can kind of imagine
someone sort of
weirdly justifying that
Because often what it's done
is you leave a tract
with a little gospel message
like instead of a tip
And I can imagine
someone kind of using
this rationale
Well, Acts 3
Acts 3, you know
Silver and gold I do not have
But what I do have
I give unto thee
Here's the good news of Jesus
And it's like okay
Maybe leave your little tract
and a gigantic tip
You know, practicing
resurrection life
Like come on people
So yeah, I think
some reading in that way
Like in other words
I don't think they really
did actually have tons of money
And they just didn't want to
I think they're probably
actually quite poor
So yeah, so okay
Let's shy away from that reading
This is not an instance of
a moment of Christians being
so heavenly minded
they're no earthly good
Like actually I mean
if you read the story
Really it's actually
the opposite of that
I mean it is
this is an instance
of Christians being
so absolutely filled
with the goodness
the love
the grace of God
that they're like
just bursting with the spirit
and they pray for someone
and there's like a healing
and actually they do
a ton of earthly
practical real life good
Right?
It's noticeable
They don't actually
hand the man like
Well here's a sermon for you
Here's a tract
Here's you know
No, they like do a lot of
a whole heck of a lot of good
So now perhaps that leads
into this other reading
which maybe can feel
a little bit distant
or removed from us
because you say
Oh well okay
Yes, agreed
They did a whole heck
of a lot of good
but this is so utterly
unrelatable to my life
because I've
I don't know about you
but I've prayed for people
and you know
it feels like a blue
once in a blue moon
like I don't
I don't know about you
maybe some folks are different
but I don't have miracles
flowing from my fingers
you know
I often pray for people
and honestly most of the time
it's not some
instantaneous miracle
and even when it is
I kind of secretly
like in the back of my mind
I'm like but maybe
just like got better
because you just got better
you know
I don't know
maybe I lack faith
maybe the pastor shouldn't say
but yeah
so I think
there can be kind of
a way of thinking
of this story
that it feels
you know
too
like
powerful
and just
you know
I just
I don't walk around
healing blind eyes
making the
the lame to walk
curing cancer
and
I mean
awesome
but it just
you know
um
yeah
and by the way
I should mention
like I don't
I'm not opposed
to these things
I really do
I think the spirit of God
can do whatever
the spirit of God wants
and everyone probably
has kind of
an approach
that I've
um
I've kind of seen
in the church
where
we kind of
we emphasize this
so much
that it's like
this is what
sort of
Christianity is like
all about
you know
it's just
and it's very
somewhat intoxicating
because it's like
it's the power of God
you know what I mean
and it's like
oh my gosh
you have the power
and I mean
there was a point
in my Christian journey
sorry I'm yelling
where I was like
yeah I mean
I really felt like
well this is
you know
channeling this power
like that's the answer
you know
and uh
I saw a strange phenomenon
that kind of happened
in those wings of the church
where um
maybe the way
I'd sum it up
is to say
it's very easy
to become more interested
in the gifts
than in the giver
in essence
more interested
in the power
and the miracles
and the you know
whatever
than like in God
it's weird
God almost gets
more obsessed
with the gifts
that God gives
and you're like
more obsessed
with that
we become more enamored
with gaining
and wielding
spiritual power
than becoming people
actually filled
with God
utterly surrendered
to the Holy Spirit
which is the point
of course
you know
like that's the beauty
where then
God does
whatever God wants
in and through us
you know
and maybe it is
like a remarkable healing
or something
or maybe
it's just
the miracle
of lovingly
caring
for someone
for years
on end
as they
suffer through
their illness
and maybe get better
at the end
and it's amazing
or maybe not
but even that
like
can be a God moment
does that
kind of make sense
where I'm not trying
to slam the idea
of God
doing an amazing thing
I'm saying
I think I'm trying
to maybe have us
see
that perhaps
God
what was really
motivating Peter
and John
in that moment
wasn't so much like
you know
an obsession
with the powers
of God
you know
but actually
something as simple
as like love
just love
just mercy
grace
that then manifests
however it manifests
in that moment
you know
but we do have
to be careful
because every
tradition
kind of has
its ways
of like
I think of traditions
that wings
the church
that really focus
for example
on like the power
of like
the rational mind
being a smart
Christian
a smart educated
you know
which by the way
again is good
but you can see
where that sort of
becomes its own
like ego trip
who's the smartest
Christian in the room
you know
it becomes a strange
kind of
competition
or those
wings of the church
that emphasize
like the power
of a charismatic
personality
you know
that can like
bring people in
or something
you know
and then all of a sudden
it's like
it's about being
that
there's a
it reminds me
a bit of a story
of
it's a wonderful
saint
Saint Francois
from
I think it was
like 17th century
or something
but
he was
at that time
he was just
known as
Francois
not saint
but a friend
and the friend
told him about
a local preacher
and apparently
this local preacher
was really good
I guess even back then
they had like
mega church pastors
or something
they were just like
incredible communicators
so this guy
came to Francois
and told him
like oh friend
ho ho ho
you missed it
this morning
this guy
whatever guy's name was
like this guy
oh
he did wonders
Francois
and
he
with a smile
I imagine
with maybe a little
coy
coy little smile
he said this
is his response
they do wonders
who are spotless
before God
and who do not
seek the gifts
of this world
like this little
you know like
in other words
be careful
of obsessing
on the
the amazing
I could kind of
imagine Peter and John
oh
you
the amazing
the big
the glorious
the amazing
the heart of it
reminds me of
first Corinthians 13
one through three
boy if I speak
in the tongues of men
or of angels
but do not have love
I'm only a resounding
gong or a clanging
cymbal
if I have the gift
of prophecy
I can fathom all
mysteries and all
knowledge
I have faith
I can move mountains
but do not have love
I'm nothing
and if I give
all I possess
to the poor
just an amazing
thing to do
that's incredible
I give
all I possess
to the poor
and even give my
over my body
to hardship
that I may boast
but I do not have love
but
gain nothing
is nothing
in other words
what matters
here
in Peter and John's
act
and in our acts
as we practice
resurrection
I think it is
the heart
of love
and compassion
like it is
the heart
of love
and compassion
like it is
the heart
of love
and compassion
like that is
the heart
of Christ
isn't it
that is where
we are in tune
with the spirit
and incredible
things begin
to happen
not just the big
and spectacular
but I mean
the meaningful
powerful
God kind of
moments
because I can
imagine
maybe
people hearing
this story
and again
feeling so removed
from it
like
I'm no
I don't have
maybe you say
I don't have gifts
gifts like that
you know
what can I do
I don't sing
I don't preach
I have no miraculous
powers or words
of knowledge
I'm not rich
I'm silver and gold
have I not
I'm not clever
I'm not
have you ever felt
like that
just like
other people
they have the gifts
but I don't
I don't have the gifts
but here's the
big idea
for today
you may feel
like you do not
have what people
need
but as children
of the living God
all friends
you always have
what they
need
love
care
attention
passion
prayer
healing
hope
goodness
grace
forgiveness
kindness
and a listening ear
an encouraging text
a prayer of healing
again that maybe
happens then
or maybe it's just
a life of
a prayer of healing
as you care for someone
for a decade
I mean
honestly
which one's more
an act of love
a momentary
oh my gosh
wow
or caring for an
aging parent
for 15 years
that's
that's what it means
to practice resurrection
like that's
that's the invitation
it kind of reminds me of
a little bit of
of parents
there's like this little joke
among parents about
you know raising
young children
especially
that the old joke is
you know
well they don't come
with a manual
you ever heard someone
say that
they don't
that's the hard part
they don't come
they're not born with a
manual
at the hospital
they don't hand you
a manual
you know
and that's
pointing to the
inadequacy
often parents feel
you know it's sort of
like you're handed
this task
and you're just
like
blah
you know
and I heard
parenting
there is a simplicity
to it
and they said
really you know
what a kid needs
at the end of the day
they need boundaries
right
to say like
hey here's the
like we're going to
act in these ways
or not
you know what I mean
like
boundaries
and love
that's about it
you know what I mean
like
that's hard
and that's kind of
what I'm getting at
you know like
what do people
really
we can make it
easy
to follow Jesus
how do I practice
resurrection
oh ho ho
you know
we kind of build
it all up
and it's like
maybe it really
is as simple
as like
God I'm here
I'm available
help me to love
help me to listen
help me to care
help me to be present
and then God
will do through us
whatever God wants
there's a story
of a
Zen
priest
was asked
what is it
you are doing
in this
and this
priest
said
caring for the sick
what are we
ever doing
but caring
for the sick
I
love that
I think about that
like once a month
at least
what are we ever
I mean
isn't that life
like it's just
it's just a
fevered world
isn't it
it's like everyone
has at least a low
grade fever
and sometimes it
spikes
metaphorically speaking
of course
you know what I mean
like
what are we ever
doing
like what is church
what is this
but caring
for the sick
you know
again not in a
putting you down
way like
we're all in it
together
we're all
you know
now
one point of
clarification
is
this isn't
about
like having
gifts
so much as
it is being
attuned
to the
source
of all
gifts
right
the gifts of
God
are less a
matter of
possession
and more a
matter of
procession
I want to
kind of emphasize
this
in other words
they flow
from God
to us
through us
to others
via the Holy
Spirit
right
which means
really our
job
and again
isn't to
kind of
say
that's
our
that's like
a sort of
wrong emphasis
it's really
really more
about being
attuned
being attuned
to the
Spirit of God
and of course
we have moments
of real
attunedness
and then maybe
not so much
I had a little
moment of
attunedness
I'll close
the story
it was just
just last
week
and
you may know
our Muslim
friends have
just come to
an end
I was actually
at
Panera Bread
this week
on I think
it was Wednesday
and there was
Rose
I'm not even
getting my
story yet
this is a
story before
the story
and I just
saw these
two tables of
people and
Muslims
because you
could tell
with the
headdress
and they
were just
praying
and then
I realized
oh Ramadan
is over
so they're
celebrating
because in
that season
they don't
eat or
drink from
dawn to
dusk
so I'm a
soccer coach
and I have
a player
on my team
a family
that is
Muslim
and this
was actually
a little
moment of
lack of
attunedness
on my
team
so I
was like
go ahead
go for
it
but later
his parents
came to
me
hey
if you
notice
he's
sluggish
he hasn't
ate or
drank all
day
oh my
gosh
I felt
so bad
so the
next game
I'm tuned
in
I'm yelling
at him
at his
parents
this was
the moment
of attunedness
I felt
the tap
on the
shoulder
metaphorically
whatever
I felt
the inner
prompting
I felt
like I
needed to
acknowledge
their religious
experience
engage with
them on
it
I don't
know if
they know
I'm a
pastor
I'm Muslim
at least in
this area
so I
wanted them
to know
so I
go across
and ask
them how
is it
going
how is
Ramadan
going
and I
kept going
deeper
what's your
experience
been like
what have
you learned
what are
you learning
about yourself
what are
you learning
about God
as I'm
just guessing
probably not a
lot of people
are asking
all the questions
and they get
to share
and it was
incredible
I don't know
if they heard
this in the
equivalent of a
sermon
but it was
a powerful
insight
they said
honestly
one thing
we love
about Ramadan
is because
of this
time
we're not
eating and
drinking
and
in that
moment
we identify
with the
poor of the
world
we know
what it is
to ache
and it was
like this
moment
where I
set out
to be a
site of
procession
so to
speak
and suddenly
the Holy
Spirit
is like
going through
them
and right
back at
me
but so
simple
be attuned
listen
love
care
so in
this season
of Easter
tide
let's look
for those
moments of
resurrection
life
and in
that moment
know that
you are
tapped into
the source
of every
good and
perfect
gift
in the name
of the
Father
so as
we come
to the
table of
the Lord
tonight
as we
take in
the body
of Christ
in the bread
the blood
of Christ
in the cup
may this
be a moment
where you
receive maybe
some of you
are here today
and you're
thinking like
love to be a
site of
procession
for others
but honestly
right now I
feel a little
like oh
may this be a
moment where
you do receive
from God
what you
need
a
symbol of
the presence
of God
as you take
God in so to
speak may it be
a moment where you
receive what you
need so that
this week you
can become
that site of
procession
that that
bread so to
speak for
for others
so
the way we're
going to
participate in
tonight is
we will just
go ahead and
we'll go row
by row
start here at
the front
we'll just
kind of work
our way back
we'll form a
line just right
here so if
you're on that
side you can
kind of come
around and
come this
way we
practice what's
called an
open table
meaning if
you're here
tonight and
you want to
participate then
you are totally
free to do
that you can
have it said
that there's no
stigma if you
if you'd rather
not that is
that's okay too
you should know
the red is wine
the white is
grape juice
and and finally
you can just
partake whenever
you'd like some
folks like to
come and kneel
and partake there
some folks return
to their seats
and partake some
people just
partake immediately
you can just do
however you
like so this
is the table
not of the
church but
it's made ready
for those who
love him and
want to love him
more so come
you who have
much faith
and you who
have little
you who have
been here often
and you who
have not been
here long
you who have
tried to follow
and you who
have failed
come
come because
it's the lord
jesus himself
who invites you
and it's his
will that those
who want to
meet him
should meet
him here
come to the table
and you who have
tried to follow
failed come to
the table
because it's the
lord jesus himself
who invites you
and it's his will
that those who
want to meet him
should meet him
here come
now
here
come
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
down
the
window
don't
look
from
inside
the
window
of
the
window
you
that
have
it
every
part
of
me
i
want
to
love
you
like
love
me
lord
every
part
of
me
i
want
to
love
you
like
love
me
lord
every
part
of
me
i
want
to
love
you
like
love
me
lord
i
don't
have
much
i
don't
have
much
but
i
have
a heart
that
beats
for
you
i
have
a heart
that
beats
for
you
i
have
a heart
that
beats
for
you
i
have
a life
i'll
give
to
you
i
have
a life
i'll
give
to
you
i
have
a life
i'll
give
to
you
i
have
a heart
that
beats
for
you
i
have
a heart
that
beats
for
you
i
have
a heart
that
beats
for
you
i
have
a heart
that
beats
for
you
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
come
see
me
i
am
from
the
heart
that
beats
for
you
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
come
see
me
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
you
soon
come
see
you
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
see
me
soon
come
i don't have much
but I have a heart, that beats for you
I have a heart, that beats for you
I don't have much
but I have a heart, that beats for you
I have a heart, that beats for you
that beats for you
for you